hey I'm swim I'm TJ online I'm Jada
Grace
[Music]
I think the best way to describe our
music is adventurous you kind of like to
play around in a bunch of genres at the
same time you got the biggie influence
over here got the Beyonce influence over
here you like to blend all of those into
like a really
fun crazy thing and yet cohesive at the
same time yeah
[Music]
so we just dropped our debut album
titled I was mature for my age but I was
still a child it's a Ode to our
childhood it's also an Ode To The Future
it's our most personal project to date
we're so excited that it's out and that
people are loving it and we're happy to
be here performing some records from it